all right so we're going to do a
beginner
chaza drill okay and this one
is uh coming in with katata DOI and then
you do whatever technique you want
okay uh there's no counters or anything
like
that no variation in the attack okay
the reason for guaza is
different at the beginning
level from the reason for kihon
was your
art follows an
ancient I don't want to say philosophy I
don't want to say say religion because
those are all tainted today but let's
say an ancient wisdom
that is a matter of
reconciling what we perceive to be
dichotomies so you have for example Yin
and Yong iin koku ADI and
Tenon mind and body the Marshall and the
spiritual and you also have kihon and gu
was this wisdom
tradition is pancultural and it is
observed throughout history across the
globe but the one that is particular or
the one that is at the genealogical
Forefront of aikido's wisdom tradition
is yinong
Theory Yin
Yong behind the yin and the Yang is a
singularity that's the
doubt what you are trying to do what is
set
up
conceptually in this
engagement with
dichotomy is to reconcile
them so that in a way they cease
functioning and when they cease
functioning the Dow will
arise so another dichotomy we have is
your first mind and your second mind or
the ego
tripartite and the god
Consciousness what you're trying to do
is
bring a sensation to the
functioning of the ego tripartite the
first mind
aspect precisely because its nature is
to experience the world and thus the are
dichotomously so when you're doing Gaza
one of the things that you're trying to
do as you're trying to do throughout
your art is stop the functioning of the
ego tripartite the stop the functioning
of the first mind aspect allowing the
god
Consciousness to
manifest there are some very common ways
that the the first
mind manifest in your guaza
training and prevent you from tapping
into the second
mind
contestation what you're going to
do more commonly than not is push back
on your
UK so even though they it the the attack
is prescribed there's going to be enough
human
[Music]
variation that it won't go exactly as
you
planned and you end up pushing
contesting Yong Yong clashing with your
ukin this is the first mind that's what
it
does and then a second most common way
is
especially once you become frustrated
with that first mistake is to start
picking techniques ahead of time before
UK comes in I'm going to do this
one okay this is an attachment to form
which is what the first mind does it
attaches to
things and again there's going to be
enough human
variation in the ukemi that sooner or
later you're going to be making the
first mistake as a result of the second
mistake meaning you're going to pick
your Technique beforehand but the way UK
came in that one is now just contesting
their
energy so you want to look for those two
areas in your training okay I don't want
to pick
techniques and I don't want to create or
generate a YY Clash contest with my UK
okay what you can also do
here is stay
playful just like when we were rolling
yesterday don't try to win you you don't
win
guaza you
either are in your first mind or you're
in your second mind so to
speak there's no
price
so as you stay playful I recommend
getting into trouble
okay this is the opposite of trying to
pick a technique beforehand you're
trying to stay out of
trouble get yourself in weird
situations okay and then you'll see from
the second mind weirdness goes away
everything's perfect okay
so let's try this okay looking for these
things so if I tell you you're you're
contesting UK or I tell you you're
picking the technique beforehand you
know I know what we're doing you know
which mind is functioning okay and then
the solution stay playful get into
trouble okay now that said you don't
want to milk the drill so you don't
want 50,000 turns
D this is also a very common thing so
you know you're not supposed to contest
you know you're not supposed to pick the
technique and now you're doing like two
three k ten con like this is not
Marshall this is not realistic this is
too much milking of the drill of the
limitations put on ukit do you
understand okay so you can't be turning
turning turning no no no and you cannot
give
back or allow UK to gain back their
balance that's not it either
okay and one thing you can
do uh to make it even more live is no
matter who the UK only the only the
really good UK is going to just stay
present with the yin yangong energy as
your resp responding to
them the afraid UK the UK who him or
herself is functioning for the ego
tripartite will try to identify your
Technique because they're attached to
form they will try to pre-identify your
Technique so they can now take the
ukemi that they want to take they oh
back breakfall do you see it and you
should be able to feel their
intention do you see and allow or work
with their disengaging energy to keep
them engaged so they don't fall where
they want to fall do do you understand
you you should not let your UK fall
where they want to fall you can make
their fear-based intention their ego
tripartite
functioning um become part of your live
training environment by going you're not
falling here you're falling over here
okay and way you can tell that is
they'll they'll you'll you'll sense the
surprise in them they'll they'll take an
inhale they'll hold their breath their
eyes will bulge they don't fall so well
okay um and so toward that end I
recommend that you go slow don't don't
go fast just train slow speed has
nothing to do with the first or the
second mind aspect whether we access it
or not okay all right so let's try this
Dr
do you feel your mind
thinking recognizing certain things oh
that oh oh this oh that whether it be oh
EO or oh Shaga didn't work or you see
that you're you're identifying this is
all first
mind these all ego triar time
okay once you understand understand the
the the the delusion of
kihon and
J the dichotomy
there there is no eeko so there is no
Nono so there's no EO that didn't
happen so there's no new thing I have to
do there's no
sequence this is followed by
that but that thinking is not part of it
this is first mind
training okay you already know first
mind first mind's dominating the world
nowadays you were
raised in the first mind with the first
Mind by the first
mind you must
enter a different
state that thinking is not part of it so
those thoughts you were told in your Zen
training and the thoughts are going to
be coming in because the first mind is
going to keep functioning do you see and
what you told release the thought
release the thought release the thought
release the thought but here you're not
you're trying to use it to calculate
what to
do it it doesn't work so if you pay
attention something is showing
up the UK is
stopping do you see you stop movement
stops it's not fluid because the mind is
not fluid because the first mind can
never be fluid it's always staccato
light as you get fettered or captured
then you got to let go then a new one
and let go and a new one like it starts
and stops and so your movement starts
and
stops and so UK starts and stops you see
and so there's Great Moments where UK is
just standing there they're not
continually traversing the mat they're
not continually being brought or kept
into kazushi you see and again that's
milking the drill that can't happen in
real life okay
so if you catch yourself thinking
identifying any of those functionings of
the intellect just release it right away
don't try to use
it and pay attention are you is UK
moving or they have they stopped okay
this is also a cue a symptom of the
first mind so you can use it to
identify where you're at okay try it
again okay uh some technical
things uh you're going slower do you see
so there's less
inertia there's less
momentum and
additionally your
UK does not know what you're going to do
so
even here because the ego tripartite
functions through fear and
self-preservation and
[Music]
reification your UK even in this
Dojo takes little Dives here in there in
kihon Wasa training do you see and so
they can't do it now because they can't
identify which technique you're going to
do do you see which meant the technique
worked the way you were doing it in
kihon because they were just taking
themselves off balance do you see well
now You' slowed down so there's less
energy and now Yuka doesn't know where
to go so they're not going to take the
dive so you have to do a fuller range of
motion so for example I'm watching your
kayen it's you're too high you never are
ever you're never gaining vertical
control of the head neck area so they're
not off balance you have their head at
waist level that's a three-point stance
now you stopped man you can't get more
stable than that do you see so you you
have to use more of the vertical plane
at this low level of inertia you're so
you're going to have to work your glutes
you're going to have to bend your knees
stop being lazy okay let's try
it okay when you do
Gua you're not trying to do K was this
you're not trying to pick a form do you
see you're not you don't pick a form
okay you're just working with energy now
not with construct
okay
so you don't do
the you
see those are all Cole endings ritual
endings in
Kona you don't do those in guaza because
UK is just responding to
the energy the yin and Yong of your
Technique and you don't have complete
control over their body and those pins
so they should be continue to keep
moving do do you understand that so you
you would have to use one of the other
pins
that you've used that are actual pins
okay does that make sense you don't so I
don't want to see you go down and do one
of the Keon pins because Yuka is just
lying there they they should be able to
keep moving okay so that means if you
want them there you have to do one of
the other pins
okay going on from this last one so you
heard me say Fuller rain of motion but
did you feel the acceleration come
on
okay that is a form of
contestation what you want to do instead
is every let's let's give a
mathematical
um perspective to it so here's the UK's
upright posture and they're going to go
to a 90 okay so every one of these
degrees you can start manipulating it as
you move it around into the kazushi
patterns either the front inward or the
back outward so to speak okay as opposed
to you go straight down and now you got
to try to accelerate them you see if you
blend incrementally with each one of
those you can get the body tilt
that takes them into the kazushi
patterns and you don't have to
accelerate them okay so look for this
also this change in your
Tempo okay in your Technique that too is
a sign that you're functioning from the
first mind okay cuz you're you're you
the first mind can't make those
adjustments like that it cannot function
at the speed of life it it understands
beginning middle end that's about it
okay and really just beginning end okay
so let's try it again and not have to
speed up okay in fact you can go quite
slow and still keep UK moving still get
them in a kazushi without letting them
regain all that kind of stuff because
you just keep uh adjusting each one of
those degrees into the kazushi patterns
okay let's try it
again
so tell me if this is not
true when you have only access to the
first
mind the iido you do is first mind
iido the iido will
not will not give you access to the
second
mind and first mind iido is a
contradiction it's
oxymoronic there's only really iido from
the second
l so the the techniques are not the
vehicle for for the sensation of the
first
M the first M
will do what it always
does it will take the technique and
you'll experience it through the first
mind you push on what's pushing on
you you intellectualize you Fetter you
stop you accelerate you
force do it'll never not do
that something to think
about you have let's say your doing Zen
and you have
zazen and in a way zazen is almost like
Gaza you can't really do zazen until you
can tap into the second
line zazen is almost like a spot
check can you do second mind or
not where you really cultivated
is where Feast is where first mind is
not allowed to
function so in your regimented
day in your strict Senpai kohai
relationship in your vow based Devotion
to the
abbit in your
work in your dietary
prescriptions if you look at the
Buddhist
Cannon you
have the
sutras the words of the Buddha the
teachings of the
Buddha then you have a philosophical
Cannon commentaries and things like
this but then you have a monastic
code and when you compare the size of
them the Buddha's words the
philosophical commentaries which is what
most of the West is drawn
to pale in comparison to the size of the
monastic
code why because it's in that
code that the true catalytic energy
necessary for self- transformation
necessary for learning the skill of
releasing the sensation of the first
first mind it's in the
code it's not in the thing where you
need the first the second mind it's not
in that thing that's just a spot
check you're not going to learn how to
bring a sensation to the first mind
aspect be in Gaza because there's really
no penalty for it you just aren't doing
like
Kido so you really have to raise up the
other Dojo
practices you're not you're not taking
them for what they truly
are they look in your mind secondary the
way a Westerner looks to the Vana and
goes oh the main part is the Buddhist
teachings or the philosophical comment
Aries and you're like someone goes why
is this if those are the main parts why
is this other part so much bigger than
these other two parts do you
see why is it Westerner after
[Music]
Westerner can go to all these meditative
ret meditation Retreats etc
etc but can't even live a a weak under a
monastic
rule why are there certified yoga
instructors vandalizing the electric
pumps and I get called to right to deal
with her
vandalism you
see put her under a real
Guru she could not make
it because the of the ego tripartite is
allowed to continue to
function in doing poses in the
studio under a
guru cannot
function ceases to function
okay so same thing here we have a Vania
you you have to take it much more
seriously we have a guru relationship
you have to take it much more seriously
as seriously as you take it and as much
as you engage in it that is how
much cultivation you're doing in the
skill of
[Music]
releasing
for
[Music]
sh
it's
[Music]
sh
come
[Music]
it's
is
[Music]
a